The next thing we are going to talk about is how can we dynamically increase
the amount of physical memory, that's available
to a particular operating system running on top
of the hypervisor? As I mentioned, memory
requirements tend to be bursty, and therefore. The
hypervisor has to be able to allocate
real physical memory or machine memory on demand
to the requesting guest operating systems on top
of it. Let's look at this picture here. Let's
assume that this is the total amount of machine
memory that's available to the hypervisor. And the hypervisor
has divvied up the available machine memory among
these two operating systems. So the house, meaning the
hypervisor has no spare memory at all. It is
completely divided up and given to these two guys.
What if the windows operating system experiences
a burst in memory usage, and therefore
its Requiring more memory from the hypervizor.
It may happen because of some resource hungry
application that had been started up in
windows, maybe a video streaming application, that
is gobbling up a lot of physical
memory, and therefore windows needs more memory and
comes to the hypervizor asking for
additional hardware resources. But unfortunately, the bank
is empty. What the hyper-visor could do
is recognize that. Well maybe, this operating
system doesn't need all of the physical resources I allocated it. So I'm going
to grab back, a portion of the physical memory that Linux has. And once
I get back this portion of physical memory that I previously allocated to Linux,
I can then give it to Windows to satisfy its sudden hunger for more
memory. Well, this principle of robbing Peter
to pay Paul. Can lead to unexpected
and anomalous behavior, of applications running on
the guest operating system. A standard approach of
course would be to coach one of the guest
operating system in this case perhaps Linux, to give up
some of its physical memory voluntarily, To satsify the
needs of a peer that is currently experiencing memory pressure.